[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum ryan teos is here
hola if you don't know ryan you haven't
listened to the show
then i hope you do listen to the show or
maybe they just skip through all the
parts that i talk maybe you know people
like we should get through stuff it's a
very
complex method of avoidance mm-hmm i
wouldn't recommend it you're still going
to therapy uh-huh still enjoying it
still helping you i think so yeah i
think so too i think uh
man i've still been having the anxiety
and the exhaustion and stuff and and you
know i think
at times it's getting a little better
but i'm still
you know
optimistic and still trying to figure it
out
that's all you can do so if you're
struggling with anxiety you know get
help there's always
there's always help out there you know
um
be good to yourself first and foremost i
mean know that people deal with it
you're not alone that's for sure um also
uh thanks for listening the podcast
thank you for making our podcast
you know your
your your uh your podcast for the week
um you know this is a guy a very funny
comedian
actor
adam ray and if you don't know him
that's fine but you're going to learn a
lot you're going to learn something
about people that you don't know so i
really appreciate those that are that
don't look at and say adam ray i don't
know adam race i'm not going to listen
or so and so i'm not going to listen
i really appreciate you guys listening
and supporting each podcast and it means
a lot um if you want to follow us on
social that's inside you podcast on uh
instagram and twitter
facebook instagram and facebook at
insideyoupod on the twitter if you want
to join patreon and support the podcast
we need you more than ever go to
patreon.com inside of you and uh become
a patron support the podcast i'll
message you as soon as i can thanking
you it's really me i do send these
messages
and there's all different top tiers some
of the top tiers uh though all the top
tiers get their names shouted out at the
end of every episode so i just really
appreciate you guys for listening and
there's so many podcasts and you know
that's all i'll say about that
um
you know i've been into a lot of cons i
want to thank everybody for seeing me in
raleigh and in boston and australia and
illinois it was a lot it was you know it
was very exhausting but it was it was
awesome to see so many people doing the
small of the nights and seeing patrons
and getting to meet some patrons that i
hadn't met before
and i just really appreciate it um
and that's all i'll say about that also
if you want to go to the inside of you
online store we've got tons of stuff
like smallville lexmas scripts signed by
me
inside you glasses and mugs and tumblers
and uh other autographed pictures from
me um
lunch boxes small lunch boxes go to the
inside you online store get you
something nice get yourself something
nice
and um
also the album sun spin my my band
sunspin our new album is coming out soon
so keep going on sunspin.com to check
out when it's available you can see a
bunch of merch there and you can book us
for a zoom you could book us for a show
sunspin.com uh without further ado this
is a very funny man i had a good time
interviewing him he had a lot of he's
very animated
um
impressions
cool story and uh he was a delight to
have on the episode a good energy i
think you're gonna really enjoy this one
let's get inside of adam ray
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you can't say that anymore
what's a pillow biter nice
pillow biter what is that actually
a pillow biter is someone who um
it's not a term they use for like bratty
kids or like
[ __ ] kids
i thought it was like you know you bite
the pillow because you're getting you're
having some
i think somebody did you ever see the
movie kids by the way oh it made me
throw up go put those heads on those
cans put those heads on kids was a movie
that before euphoria it was startling it
was a startling i remember he had aids
and he was like kind of a wheelchair and
like i i don't even yeah i have no legs
was a song i think that someone sang who
didn't have legs
really yeah
it was a movie it was a musical it
wasn't but there was a kid that sang a
song in a wheelchair about not having
legs i had a part of that house party
don't remember that i remember when
someone showed that to me i think it was
sixth or seventh grade and i'm growing
up in lake forest park washington baby i
work at the local albertsons
i've got you know the get the girl in
the service deli is trying to you know
give me hand jobs in exchange for you
know uh credibility wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait because she's 26 i'm
17. she offered you hand jobs for
credibility well no i just i say that
what i mean by that is i was younger at
the grocery store right she was older i
think she dug the idea of being with a
younger dude and i
didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing
you hadn't had sex by that point however
how old were you 17 17. yeah i didn't
have sex until i was like 18 years old
that was about yeah i think 19 with
money not by choice high school
girlfriend not by choice really well
yeah i think you want to have some
charismatic fellow yeah but i was the
shortest kid in my high school i was
nervous i always i didn't i did yeah you
know short
i knew actually you weren't sure no i
take that back goal uh there was a kid
named bob bergstrom i'll say his full
name he uh it's a great dude used to
wear overalls with no shirt and crush
the woman
uh sexual assault woman
sorry it's early
he would crush the woman i was trying to
think i don't want to say crush the
quote
you crush the um
the the sex uh the sex game the game of
sex really he would play a game that i
didn't know much about
be now was it truly
only just your call or do you think like
there are other factors other than that
sure i don't think i started puberty
till late so i had no hair on the um
genitalia girls want that uh no they
don't no they don't but they want to
know you can get it do you know i've
talked about this ryan you know i've
talked about this but like we play
sometimes
uh was it called shirts and skins
and uh if i was a skin i'd say i'll take
the zero i'm not i can't play yeah and i
remember mike curry i've talked about
this mike curry had the hairiest armpits
and i was so jealous i used to pray for
armpit hair and
and he was like rosenbaum why don't you
have armpit hair you're you're 16 years
old and i'm like i'm a swimmer
he's like what i'm like you know it's
aerodynamics i knew i was smart enough
to to know about swimmers so i used that
but i wasn't really it's a great excuse
it was i didn't have any hair armpit
hair you were harry i envied you yeah i
started shaving i think sixth grade
summer i was in arizona with my dad and
stepmom and he brought in a razor and
he's like i think you're gonna need this
and i was like oh now you want to be in
my life
uh by the way that's an incredible
indiana jones statue do you like the
indiana statue it's unbelievable this is
a magnet like it said so it's kind of
heavy it's like the what do you call
this the
the baby
buddha wasn't the baby buddha from major
league joe boo no i don't know what that
is it's just but anyway it's what
indiana jones gets am i sitting where
mark paul gossler sat what did you do
yes he was sitting right where you said
no he was uh on his own he was on zoom
he was in a zoom i mean look
you've had a lot of
fantastic people on your podcast so have
you on your podcast but that one was
very cool to me really why is it that
you had a crush on mark paul no crushed
a big crush on kelly kapowski oh yeah
yeah and brad and i when brad williams
was doing about last night with me we
went to
her house and had tiffany amber on and
that was that was a real treat but mark
paul come on man didn't get cooler than
that when you were growing up really
you're saved by the bell fan you watched
it hey man the college years i mean
everybody i didn't watch the college
years though well then yeah if you
didn't watch the college years and you
didn't see mike golick be the r.a for
their
dorm floor and you didn't see
[ __ ]
the hawaiian style movie with with mr
carosi and leah remini scientology no
did you ryan no
no
all right let's shift gears sh just
shift him hey by the way you grew up in
seattle yeah were you a only child
no i was my mom's sister and dad and i
then folk split then mom and a sister
and i my sister went away my mom calls
me one day and she goes hey um can you
have a kirk's mom i was staying at my
buddy's place uh drop you off your
sister and her boyfriend uh took all
your clothes and all your money and a
bunch of my money and some of our [ __ ]
and took the van and they're gone and i
was like
yeah i'll get a ride
and so uh come back home and then they
were just on their way to az
and then ended up she went to a girls
school right from
oregon where they ran out of gas and for
about three years and so it's just mom
and i pretty much through high school
was that tough not having like a father
figure around there
because
then you don't know any different
probably you know what then in
retrospect what do you think i've
thought about this uh
i still have not done therapy and have
you not done any therapy i went twice
when they split my mom made me go to a
marriage counselor and the guy was like
he had a little plastic hoop
and uh basketball yeah and i would
always come in and shoot because i'm a
big basketball guy and i would shoot and
and
for probably the whole hour and then
like sit down for the last five minutes
and you'd be like
so uh
are you feeling any better when i go
no no
see you next week and he just wouldn't
push me and then one day i remember went
in and i shot
and uh
bounced off the rim he just [ __ ] one
arm grab the offensive rebound and goes
we're gonna talk today
no more shooting hoops until we talk and
i was like oh tim allen style he was
serious yeah i sat down and i still
barely opened up and i was just like who
the [ __ ] are you man what kind of
questions do you ask because how old are
you as a kid he asked me like
this was probably i was nine so 91. nine
years old what are you asking now ask me
questions like who do you want your mom
to bang next uh without saying bang i'm
joking he no he would he would say would
you like your mom to be where did he
touch you no he would go um
he would uh what would he say like what
just very generic i think the idea of
talking to someone that i had no like
no connection to i'm like bro there's
already a lot to unpack here and i think
this is partly into why i'm a comedian
and
why i've probably not
and dealt with it in pieces as i've
gotten older but i just go it is what it
is
like
dad's moving on i want mom to be happy i
really have no control over this i'm
gonna kind of just like it's easier just
to push down and press on than it is to
like i was like i'm a kid i had some
awareness of like i don't want to have
to like go through all this so let me
just go what is it going to dad's i got
two houses now is that kind of how it is
you're like how do i get through this
yeah let's just get through it i don't
need to talk about it don't address it
dude yes don't address it yes
so and uh
and
i don't think it's like
hurt me i definitely
you say that with pause for sure
i definitely
looking back go i i wouldn't want to any
other way because my mom crushed it
single mom four jobs her and i became
best friends and enemies because it was
like i'm in this formidable time is that
the right word
formidable that could be
influential impressionable time sure is
impressionable that sounds pretty cool
you're talking to me i'm like general
english
so there's a time where i did take a
word power course dude code made you
forget words give me your best word your
biggest word throw it at me
the word that just came to mind was
conundrum after that [ __ ] after that
uh supercalifrag you look at listic it's
see
put that one out you don't have that one
if you say it
round enough you always have to close it
what is it the how the song go
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious even
though the sound of it is something
quite controversial atrocious if you say
it loud enough you'll always sound
precocious super guy
listen it gets me out i don't know do
you remember that rhymes you're the
cartoon dance and then [ __ ] dick van
dyke comes in doing the step ball change
they're done
i gotta get dick van dyke for you joke
after this after the podcast
i i'm surprised though that you're how
old are you 39 39 years old and you have
not ever i'm not surprised i don't want
to tell everybody that i can't believe
you're not in therapy hey have i been
told to go yeah by who girlfriends
ex-girlfriends my sixth grade girlfriend
no yeah uh
a lot of um
yeah my mom
and not even for
i think there's been times when i've
probably gotten angry about stuff that
it wasn't about and then people like my
mom or whatever go
it's it's not about that it's about that
so go deal with that and and again it's
just like i know a lot of comedians that
do it
um you are you also a member of the
therapeutic tribe
yeah yeah oh yeah and swear by it i'm
sure right yeah so as ryan ryan started
not that long ago we know ryan's in
therapy i came in and this guy looked
like he was getting ready to lay down
again
he's ready i thought you were a
therapist yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
ryan but it's working right yeah i mean
yeah it comes at my eyes i get it yeah
yeah but
well yeah no no you're a soccer you're a
sweet kid and i i get i get gentle
therapy like it worked for me vibes from
your eye are women always trying to fix
you
uh or vice versa so i'm always i became
a so it was just mom and i growing up
and then sister came back and i was the
peer mediator at like eight before my
sister actually bounced uh when i was in
middle school i was peer mediator so it
was like at eight and nine like mom and
sister would be just f and i would like
go in separately and calm down and bring
them together like crazy so always a
fixer people pleaser just wanting things
to be cool again just wanting to make it
okay
that's why i loved actually didn't love
the school whatever but
all the aspects of school and being
social and being involved in plays and
sports and
and so much because that was a
distraction man once i got home it was
like oh man that was this heavy cloud of
like just what what's happening
you know and my mom being sad and sister
being you know uh just a little wild and
taking my mom down and then dad [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and and them just trying to
figure it out so school was like man i
don't have to think about any of that
right now so you like at school i mean
liked the i like going to
and then once i started to become a
funny kid
when was that when was in sixth grade
sixth grade so i was a fat kid getting
teased a lot fat you were overweight
yeah man like when you say oh when you
say fat you mean fat or you mean just a
little overweight so take uh lizzo and
add 12 pounds who's lizzo
come on who's was that come on really
the um
the music artist i don't know
i'm stuck in the 70s and 80s it's fine
lizzo huh well uh
guys sorry about this no it's fine not
you i'm sorry with my audience for not
knowing nobody should be surprised that
a guy with an indiana jones statue
doesn't know thank you thank you you're
also fine by the way there's so many
artists i don't know yeah she just is
she had a moment enough to where you go
all right i can't ignore
uh understanding who this person is for
a little bit okay and so you like her
big presence i like her music not even
that just using the example of someone
oh something a little larger than life
she's a little larger than i i don't
know but she's okay so you're happy
she's probably pushing two and a half
bills okay
i said i had 12 pounds of that that was
a joke so that's you that you were a big
kid big kid um to where like when i went
on a diet in this at the sixth grade
party and they had all these snacks
around teachers would go ray
you're reaching for vegetables but
there's pizza right there just [ __ ]
no shame teachers being like
hey you fat [ __ ]
why are you going for the veggies we
know you want to just motorboat that
pepperoni terrible and i was like yeah
you know just pete doesn't sound good
just trying to make a joke
let me ask you though let me ask you
where were you did you think that the
weight issue happened when your dad left
yikes dude probably okay i'm just
throwing that at you these are things
you learn from therapy yeah of course
but also i know that and that's not
worth going to break that like i know
that i was uh bumming and that's
probably why i started doing that
comfort food all that [ __ ] and then
i just had enough and i was like
and my grandpa would even say you know
you can't wear sweatpants it's your bar
mitzvah
sounds like me which was like such a
great passive way of being like hey
chunky legs you know you [ __ ] got
chicken breasts for tits and chicken
thighs for legs and i was like all right
man and so uh people really harassed you
though they laid it in i used to do a
joke about that it's like i didn't know
as a fat kid until i got signs from
people like i was such a happy-go-lucky
kid so until like a dad was like hey you
got time for a titty [ __ ] after you
finish that pop-tart like that would be
the way that would joke that would be
the way that i go oh man i have maybe i
should make a change because i get
so and most of my friends wouldn't uh
say anything or care because they didn't
but then some kids are cruel and they
use it to to get at you and so uh i
finally started losing weight and just
dropped it like that because i was so
out how old
sixth grade is seventh grade probably
lost 40 to 50 pounds
and uh which was all i needed which was
changed your life oh yeah and but again
i was so when i was a fat kid i started
making people laugh
and i was the funny kid now so that's
why i started chasing that it came easy
i was doing impressions of friends and
teachers we'd prank call uh this girl
that we all had a crush on as a guy
friend of ours that she had a crush on
i'd pretend to be him and i'm sorry i'd
pretend to be her to him so i'd do the
girl voice and call him as her
just yeah diabolical but just like all
sorts of that type of [ __ ] where i was
like oh look how good i'm making people
feel versus how awful i was being made
feel
it was just so hey man didn't need
therapy to figure that out i was like oh
cool i'm going to keep doing that
because it feels good and it feels it
feels good for me and i'm making people
um
happy
now a word from our sponsor better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
that's how our brains work so why don't
we treat them that way
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and care into keeping them
healthy there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain learning a new
language or taking power naps there's
also better help online therapy better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions it's more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by freedom grooming
where was freedom grooming when i needed
them when i was on smallville
bald
people nicking my head
with razors
and to all my bald friends
we found something for you it's freedom
grooming at freedom grooming we make the
flex series electric shaver which is
uniquely designed to flex and contour to
the curve of your head for a smoother
faster and safer shave without the risk
of nicks cuts irritation or ingrowns
while our grooming products work
anywhere on the body our strongest
demographic is with our bald community
and our advertising speaks to them we
are proudly supporting our hair free
customers and their journey to bald hood
you know i have some bald friends i have
some friends that are going bald and
this is the perfect product for them i
gave one recently to my friend joe
and joe
loves this product
talk about easy to use
safe
and just feels like
you know it gets the job done quickly
without the uh the knicks and the cuts
and the irritation and the ingrowns and
also guys take a look at their custom
reviews for freedom grooming it's
outstanding this is a product that you
want to have get the smoothest shave of
your life flexible blades contour to the
shape of your head for a baby smooth
shave every time shave 50 more hair in a
single stroke compared to traditional
razors expect shave times of two to
three minutes not 10 to 15. and never
cut yourself shaving again the flex
series safeguard technology means no
nicks no ingrown hairs and no problems
also we have over ten thousand five star
reviews
since even the sharpest blades dull with
use freedom created the close shave plan
with the close shave plan you'll never
run out of fresh sharp blades delivered
to your door every six weeks with free
shipping all active close shave plan
members are upgraded to a lifetime
warranty and it's completely
customizable adjust skip or cancel your
plan anytime and to thank you for being
such a loyal listener we're partnering
with freedom to give you an exclusive 20
off when you go to
com freedomgrooming.com inside that's
freedomgrooming.com
inside
when do you feel sad how often do you
get set because look i've seen like you
have such a body of work like you've
done i mean pam and tommy hacks young
rock curb your enthusiasm development
baller silicon valley i mean rick and
morty workaholics the the list goes on
and on you've done so much work and i'm
like okay he's got a
stand-up uh comedy uh
tour tour i mean like all these things
going on with yeah and i always think
but what's what's going on behind what
happens when he gets home when he's
alone what happens i i think about that
with a lot of people because i think
about that with myself i'm like making
everybody laugh i'm the center of
attention i'll look at him i'm having a
party i'm going to the beach and then i
get home and i go why am i miserable
totally are you that no
but i definitely have i mean
i all i know about being a gemini is
that you got um two sides right
so
i'm not too astrological aside from that
but i do have a
um not life of the party
switch but like the performing ability
and to be able to
hang and like um
like last night went to uh see uh my
buddy dana carvey and spade do a live
pod with sandler and then went to the
comedy store and this is doing a live
podcast then a carving spade
they were on they were on the
stage yeah and they had sandler come on
it was for two hours it was incredible
man
just seeing these guys their homies and
legends just mix it up was like really
cool and sandler you just how often you
get to see him out and about live
for longer than a talk show appearance
it was very cool man and talking about
real [ __ ] real [ __ ] and
it was just awesome they were just you
can tell being buddies and having
camaraderie really really matters
and then when did a spot and i was just
like on cloud
uh 99 the whole uh night and with a
couple buddies my fiancee and we were
just having a good time and then
and then yeah like definitely you get
home there is that like drop in energy
and adrenaline that you just kind of
but i
i uh you address it you're aware of it
yeah i also just do a good job of
thinking this is probably something i
innately did when i was younger which
was try to make sure i'm so busy like
knowing that i had this to look forward
to
was
got me juiced for going to bed and
getting up so like and when i have
things like that i'm i don't i can't
bump like i got but there's something to
be said about that though because
don't you have to learn how to be alone
don't you have to learn how to not be
business oh i have to learn how to be
alone i mean i was alone for i mean
until i met my fiance i mean that whole
time from
you know i probably fight and also being
a comic you are always alone i mean it's
like and being single and just be i mean
it's such a solo adventure in this
business you're alone
and so
i i i think the business for better for
worse has made me
thicker skin all the rejection and the
look there's been times yeah for sure
that i've been very low from probably
a mixture of like family stuff which has
just been a lot of
uh
and then the business where you're just
like man like i just need a w in one of
these departments to like pick me out of
it
and not to say that that makes you
stronger
but um i mean look i definitely
wish
no kid ever get teased
for anything
kids are cruel that stuff really stands
you know what that's like oh yeah and
especially with the weight stuff like i
even see one of my nieces now she's
actually in the past few months gone
through a little bit of a growth spurt
but she was starting to get it and man
that just ate at me and made me so sad
to where i was like i'm gonna fly up
there and beat the [ __ ] out of a
nine-year-old
and there's no there's no stopping me
and the guy at the delta desk is like i
advise against that you got that far i'm
going to remember you know what that
means
i could do anything i want to do
anything and so uh
and you have to back me up and and so
but then again like the t's like again i
am who i am i'm the amount of empathy
and compassion i have for people how i'm
such a people person why i love doing
crowd work on uh stage why i talk to
everybody and i you know probably have
more uh
you know i'm nice to everybody at the
comedy clubs and that probably comes
from a place if we're gonna do some
therapy yeah
just not wanting anyone to feel bad
because of
the times when i go oh i that was awful
and and having buddies even at that age
that's i think what put it over the edge
is when you go there's kids at school
that might tease you but then when you
have buddies that like start to jump on
the train and you're like oh i thought
you were like
not about that but no one's immune to
like
[ __ ] being cool or saying something
to
pick themselves up you know with the
crowd yeah the cool people hey i'm part
of that and no judgement but uh
but yeah so that's and my thoughts is
the same way she you know had a a not uh
great you know family environment in in
some regards and so she's so like
i just want to keep it a hundred and
positive as much as possible really but
but same thing like we both uh
you know life gets you into a
a dark uh time it it but we just um
we're good about like picking each other
up and and being like yo count the count
the blessings versus what you don't have
which is what this business you can
probably attest to that uh as well where
you're like
when can you adjust your mind to like
to to really think what's going on what
have i stacked on in the last couple
years versus what have i not
achieved and it's such an easier said
than done way of thinking but but being
insatiable is not always good yeah it's
not good at all i think if you're always
expecting like i i i need more i gotta
have more i gotta and you realize but
that's not making you happy and it
hasn't made you happy success hasn't
made me happy it's been a temporary
happy it's more uh you know i always say
it's like the colander you know it's
like you know it just goes right through
like you know water goes right through
the column yeah it's like it's ephemeral
it lasts
minutes yeah you're like oh my god i'm
great i'm really great
okay wait when can i be great again i've
got to prove myself again i've got to do
this again and then you guys you're like
what am i chasing
and i i you know for me i think that
it's like you know hey love
love memories relationships connections
those are the most important things in
the world
and uh
so that's what you know i'm working on
that more but like you know it's you
know for somebody who i didn't have it
growing up when i was going through
the it factor well i was you know
dysfunctional family like many people
i've talked about it but like i didn't i
didn't feel loved i didn't feel like i
you know
and so i looked for it elsewhere and all
of a sudden i was the funny guy and i
was like oh i'll make everybody laugh
and then you know i my friends would
their parents would be my surrogate
parents yeah you know i would make them
laugh and i'd stay weeks over their
house wow um and then i was the funny
guy and i think at that point as a small
boy i realized
you're gonna be accepted if you're funny
if you're just being the funny guy and
don't be your boring stupid ignorant
self that's how i thought and i went
through that for years until through all
my success
make people laugh be good be on you're
great you're great and eventually you
just go
wow i'm [ __ ] tired yeah and i don't
know who the [ __ ] i am yeah and that
just gets old and you gotta i don't want
to be 90 and go
what was i doing it for was that who was
i doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] for that's a
good impression that you're in 90 by the
way i i don't think i'll be alive at
night
i think he will you think so yeah and
that voice sounds like a guy that takes
care of himself because 90 90 should be
a little bit more like that i don't know
my grandfather he was 92 when he passed
away and he was like
mike you know you shouldn't fart all the
time great shouldn't fart yeah i always
fart
he doesn't like that you fart well he'd
say you know you're going to do that
you're not going to know you did it
awesome but then i'll be like right
you're pretty sure you have this face on
it you're going to do it and not know
you did it farts what did i do whoever
smelled the delty yeah exactly uh yeah
that
man okay well you're preaching to the
choir because yeah i think me with this
full head of steam of like let's just
[ __ ] push it down worry about it
later make people happy feel good that's
a better
easier more fun path
yeah and then
but to my detriment it probably
uh
you know
it's uh allowed me
to uh not figure out who i am on and off
stage quicker right right because i was
like well let's not
be that guy that you are let's be
but also again but you're on the flip
side i feel like i'm
i am who i am because of all that [ __ ]
right because of like the the the
being uh bullied and the folks thing and
and seeing my mom and dads like just how
tumultuous that was
and uh and wanting to be on top of that
and just have a a glass-half-full
approach i am who i am because of all
that so i can't there's no part of me
that really wants to
that would say
would i be this if they [ __ ] figured
it out and kept their marriage together
and stayed in love right probably not
you know maybe not maybe not because
maybe i would it's true i became someone
because of you know through uh their
relationship and what was happening
around me you become your own person but
you're a product of your own environment
yes right so there's that dysfunction
that you don't even know is there that's
just lingering waiting to get out here
and there and it gets out sometimes you
do things and you act out and you're
like oh that guy came from a [ __ ] up
place totally yeah and there's people in
your life that hopefully like point that
out and go oh you did that because of
that but you don't know that yet because
you haven't gotten anything yeah yeah
you'll learn that but you know what also
i have to say i i wouldn't get so caught
up in therapy and all these things it's
not like you know everybody i think i do
believe that everybody should you know
see therapy sure you know have therapy
at some point just kind of evaluate have
someone objective talking to them but
like you know i mean too much of
anything is probably not good for you
right you don't want to get you know
because what you're doing is working for
you is it not i think so i also just
feel like i
i don't ever like to stew on stuff for
too long so the times i have gotten
lower down i allow myself to feel that
for sure
but not
feel bad for myself and i always
if i i feel like i'm making a meal out
of it if i am
going to therap if i'm doing something
like that to really expand
i've gotten good at
and not just like suppressing but like
sitting back feeling it taking it in
and then knowing i
and allowing myself to to feel that
so much so that i'm like
uh
i don't want to feel like this again so
what are you gonna do differently that
led you to this right was it you let
yourself stew on
some jobs you didn't get or a job you
did and you weren't pumped about or some
things with some friends [ __ ] or
some family stuff like what
you know be in more control of that so
that we don't get to this spot again
right so i feel like i've always been
good about just like breaking it down
for myself and going like why you like
this and not feeling bad and being
you know able to pick myself out of it
and i take pride in that well i think
you're like i honestly think you're a
great guy you're one of those guys when
i see it like harlan's house oh yeah
harlan williams or i see out i'm like
he's just a no you're just a you don't
feel like i'm putting on a no no i
always just say like adam's adam adam's
just a good guy he wants to have a laugh
he wants to have a moment he's just he's
not he's not like i'm always present he
doesn't have ulterior motives he's just
trying to be in the be in the moment
yeah man have as much
have as many goofs uh and uh and good
times as possible yeah and like that's
what's cool about our business is like
you can really surround yourself with
people that oh yeah that's all
like i mean as soon as i came in here i
was just like [ __ ] dude
it's rules
you're like [ __ ] rules man i see that
i think people see my like those come in
and see my house i'll see all the things
i have and i'll think you're happy
you've got all these things well
no that's not what i thought i
definitely was like there's something
going on here but there's too many
puppets too many puppets
and if anything there's not enough
puppets by the way
no it's it's just a it's a i like that
you
take uh pride and an interest in
celebrating the cool [ __ ] you've gotten
to do
that's very cool because we don't do
that enough in any
uh
facet of life
but i mean come on man like you built a
very cool thing for yourself
you got like a bunch of cool baseballs
up there i'd love to like know all about
i mean you've got some [ __ ] you just
got a nice variety of uh of stuff that's
all because of what you did yeah and and
uh
and sometimes i should sit back and look
at and go these are cool things this is
a good thing if you're not you
definitely should yeah and i'm again
preaching to the choir but like
yeah we don't we're you know too much
this business doesn't there's no course
to be like every now and then [ __ ]
looking you know look in the rearview
mirror and see where you came from it's
just like because exactly it's
conditioned us to be like what's next
it's why they go up to people who've
just won the super bowl and go
[ __ ] can you guys do it again and
you're like hey man just did it let me
[ __ ] sit in that for a minute and go
to disney world or or panera yeah
right you know you'll do all these
things and then you know somebody will
make you feel like my agent has a
propensity for making me feel like [ __ ]
inadvertently he uh oh boy he will uh
just go dude this is it this is it this
is the part this is i go i i don't
really i don't want to go somewhere for
eight months and in the middle of
nowhere and do this
and i feel guilty and i'm like i'm
thinking about more about what he wants
sure as opposed to what i want sure and
um
you know there comes a time in your life
when you have to just go i want to do
what makes me happy that fulfills me
yeah because if you just keep doing what
other people expect you to do and you oh
you're you're you're adam ray you're
supposed to do this this is what you
let's keep on this and you're just
i mean you do things because you love
them oh yeah you don't have you you say
no
yeah i've gotten better at it
like even and i mean you know if i want
to go stand-up's been great for that
because it's like
a friend's birthday thing or whatever
that i like the people but i'm like i'd
rather go do a show i'd rather and
there's part of that that's like i'd
rather work
and so and not waste a uh a day or an
opportunity but it's also all fun
somebody just asked me the other day
because i'm on you know i was just in
uh
madison wisconsin for a weekend then
drove to milwaukee uh on
thursday through saturday was madison
then drove to milwaukee because they
just opened an improv there so i did a
night there so you just rent a car and
go from city to city i've never done
that did this time just because my agent
was like do you want to i can add on
this after the weekend it's close and i
was like yeah i want to do that new club
and then drove to chicago after the show
to fly out of chicago
and that was really fun and now coming
up i'm going to uh new york because my
mom's going to be out there for a bit
and i want to kick it with her
and i was supposed to go to north
carolina but the show i'm shooting dates
moved so north carolina to be canceled
but i'm going to go to new york to kick
with mom cause she's going to be out
there with some homies and my mom's just
getting older and i was like let's go
stay with a homie and hang with her in
new york and just be around her and
then i'll go from there to atlanta and
then from and then i'm gonna stay in
atlanta for a few days
because some people from young rock are
gonna be down there so i'm gonna stay
with them and then go from there to
kentucky i'm going to rent a car and
drive five hours to touch this and i'm
going to do all that yeah and i'm like
oh that sounds like a lot but that
sounds awesome and uh nothing sounds
awesome to me i think that's the problem
that sounds funny nothing i know i have
buddies that are musicians that are like
you have so many opportunities to lay
flat and you don't like and i'm not
judging you for that but whoa
and i'm like yeah man because uh because
i also love it and it's also being a
comedian you're conditioned you have to
live a life worth writing about i also
though like i've never been to kentucky
i'd love to drive into kentucky that
sounds like a cool thing with no kids
you know and and a zest for it right now
i want to take advantage of that yeah
and um
and uh and i used to always be like [ __ ]
i can't ever leave l.a i don't want to
miss out on everything so if i am in a
space where i'm like oh yeah go do that
like then i want to do that um i mean
[ __ ] when i opened for my
buddy uh joy mack and the new kids on
the block and their concert cruise that
sounded bonkers but i'm like i'm gonna
go on the cruise and open for them
because and i had i missed a couple you
know
opportunities because of it but i was
like that [ __ ] sounds like something
i'll never do if i don't do it now
um just to say you did it you ever you
ever
get nervous about no one's showing up to
your gigs do you ever think about that
no
why because all the players are playing
are
good places there's built-in places that
are that bringing comedy on state uh
just in madison has been is a like
staple of so you know people are going
to be there not even because of you
they're going to be there yes yes clubs
are good at that and the rooms i'm
playing are rooms that just are on top
of that but now also it's and that's why
i'm also doing so much uh of the road
now because of the last few years being
a nice little boost on a handful of
fronts so more people are coming out
because of that so i wanted a handful of
what like uh a lot of people always come
out from all my adam corolla appearances
from ipod growing um all the shows in
the last few whatever uh years now my my
listeners will come a thousand percent
man
god bless you man like yeah
adamwrightcomedy.com for tour dates
where's my tour today admirate.com
adamrightcomedy.comratecomedy.com
yeah make sure we know that do you have
a um what's the what's your demo of
listeners do you know you know it's it's
kind of split it's kind of split right
down the middle it's like um
i don't know what is a demographic it's
like uh
26 to 45 55. perfect yeah it's all in
there it's all in there it's a good mix
i have to look but or maybe that's my
instagram like when you'll do a live
show who's coming out i want to do a
live show i've never done one mike
because i fear that no one's going to be
there oh man not the case also just
stack it up with some homies man
really get harlan joel maybe me if you
want to [ __ ] you know so do my
podcast on the road and have a couple of
intros oh man a thousand percent you're
so good do it live oh dude yeah get the
[ __ ] out of here what are you just
nervous to know what i thought about it
i had two bookings in austin texas and
then the cove it happened i had two full
sold out places but i have my guest was
zach levi and we were going to do it and
then it sold out
i mean then it got covered then covered
up had you sold tickets yet for it it
sold out that's what i'm saying dude but
that was because of zach levi not me
but maybe a little bit of both see
that's how i think that's what's [ __ ]
up about me it is i go it's because of
zach you're not me no one wants me no i
have to have somebody's not true because
i know you're not doing a first-time
show it's you you've established your
pot it's uh it's a part of the fun in
people's lives
but you do need a big guess for the live
stuff because you do want because you
don't want to run the risk of it being a
small uh
you know gathering so so that's the
right move but right they're coming
because they want to yeah dude no it's
but
allow yourself to to know that it's both
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna do it i
think alive we should we should do a
live crush we're gonna do a live one
ryan
sure i think that would be a blast bro
you don't even have to i mean do we get
bryce to fly in we'll do one maybe
you'll have welling as the guest here in
california we'll do like dude there's so
many venues you could even do it at the
[ __ ] main room of the comedy store
and and just go all right i gotta get
350 people in there or
hotel cafe i mean dude there's so many
spots you know where you can go all
right do i want to do like a 50 seat
then you just kind of prepare and you
just shoot the [ __ ] you do what i'm
doing like this
you do this obviously you got people so
you're like oh maybe there's a little
bit more
showiness but not really last night with
spade and sandler and yeah they're sold
out right oh yeah and they're all uh but
also you had john melanie at the forum
in chappelle at the hollywood bowl so
did you hear he got attacked on stage
yeah i saw that
crazy huh how do you feel about all that
um because you know do you think do you
think it has anything to do with that
will smith uh oh yes rock that you do oh
yeah you think that people have that
they feel like they have the privilege
now i don't think it's gonna i saw
somebody post on facebook here we go
chappelle like i'm like all right man i
that's
uh
you're going too far with it i think i
don't think it's going to be as crazy as
people think i think it definitely
gave the same way that uh
you know some of the outlandish things
that uh that trump would get on tv and
say gave a voice to people that think
like that to go oh cool i can just start
walking into burger kings and being like
there aren't any jews here are there
like you know what i'm saying like it
gave it's giving people a reason to go
like oh yeah if i don't like something
but i don't think it's going to be
you know yeah i don't want to get all
political and [ __ ] i just was wondering
how you know you get kind of like it
sucks it definitely but i've always felt
that way it's a it's
it's weird to just be up there and like
most comedy clubs
and venues like they got security but
like
no one's really thinking you're taking
care of people that might be too sauced
up or that are
just um
you know a distraction and not in terms
of like someone's gonna rush the stage
and again it does happen but like
i've rarely seen i mean there's a kid up
in seattle i know that got hit at an
open mic with a guy
he uh with a bat and um i mean dude he
was like a half a centimeter away from
like just that being a wrap and he got
all these
skull and brain surgeries and now he's
living a great life and and not doing
stand-up anymore still doing it not as
much but yeah but like just at an open
mic like a guy he wouldn't let on a show
came back the following week because the
guy was like awful and always be drunk
and was like just being rude to people
and so he said you can't come to a guy
came anyway and hit him with the bat in
his head yeah
and that type of [ __ ] makes me go oh
yeah there's nothing to stop and this
guy last night like how do you get
through
there's always
there's also
you're putting yourself out do you ever
feel like that because you're always
you're always like people are heckling
you and you're always you know free
balling just going out there and just
rocking off the cuff off the cuff and
you say [ __ ] do you ever worry about uh
this guy just said that to you and he
looks a little pissed maybe and uh i'll
comment on that during the show to the
guy if that if i truly feel like it's
but then like that just happened in
irvine a few weeks ago and then there
was this big guy named gustavo that i
was having some fun with and so then it
became a thing of like
gustavo's got my back if this guy tries
to pull some [ __ ] but
but but then i always try to kill it
with kindness and make sure that i'm not
ever and the next thing about my crowd
work that i don't like that i learned
from our boy harland was
uh a to listen and be uh
to not be a dick about it and like
hit the hit em and hug em thing you know
what i'm saying where it's like we all
gotta [ __ ] with people so get a little
that but then like you know bring it in
be like i'm just [ __ ] around you know
marlon's is the he says the i mean he is
the king of random [ __ ] oh yeah i just
there's one of no there's only one
harlem williams i mean he's like sir
have you ever uh made love to a dairy
queen uh blizzard on a hot saturday
night
uh no well you're not living or you will
yeah yeah he just says these random
things man ma'am if you could look away
i'm doing a show please
yeah sorry i don't like your [ __ ]
eyes can you go to sleep i like your
eyes did he ever say that oh yeah i
don't like your eyes
for about a year and a half and i just
saw him just do some like
phenomenal [ __ ] man that was like
next level and it just made me go oh i
gotta i want to do that i want to get
good he was just like you got to listen
you got to trust to build a moment
gather some info and then just about
doing it getting reps of like trusting
yourself to
think of the funny thing and then say it
and then not you know what i'm saying
because when i would first start doing
crowd work i wouldn't listen
so i'd be you know talking like this and
then like oh where are you from or or
what you know is how long have you guys
been together and then i'd be like [ __ ]
20 seconds went by and there were no
laughs i'm thinking that not listening
to what they're just saying so then they
stopped talking and i'm like yeah you
guys look like you're not gonna make it
you know you just say something to panic
to fill in the time and then you're like
and everyone's like all right [ __ ] that
was weird
um so you learned
have you ever sit in the silence how
long did you bomb how many times have
you bombed i mean how many times have
you rose and bombed
come on
in your life how many nice a lot uh oh
yeah getting going i mean look i did
plays you know all through high school
and college so i was always comfy on
stage and that's just the writing so um
so uh
yeah i mean
yeah probably
once you're getting up there you go i
you know in this the sets are six seven
eight minutes you're like
i can get laughs throughout this but
yeah am i gonna crush for eight minutes
no that takes a minute to be [ __ ]
great but then i went to this random
comedy festival in calgary somehow like
when i was three years in and i remember
having like a string of good shows and i
was like all right [ __ ] here we go and
then getting a little too ahead of
myself and then coming back to la
and being like oh no that was just that
was just out there and like for whatever
reason like that was then translate yeah
and uh
but that you get better i always say too
it's like you know you you always want
to get off stage with a positive and a
negative i immediately try to
not beat myself up over at which i you
know
do a lot but i sorry troll all right
what was what was great here that was
cool and what's something to work on not
even like good and bad but what's
something to work on what could i my
fiance always gives me [ __ ] about that
because i'll literally get home and go
oh man
i should have said that in that moment
and said for that joke or when this
crowdwork thing happened i was like what
ah should have said that when he said
that she's like the moment's over it's
done yeah dude it's like i stopped doing
that i go no no i'm not upset or beating
myself up this is how i also like it but
like process reviewing the game tape you
know what i'm saying but it's like i see
because i record my sets and and
sometimes i listen and sometimes i don't
but if i can immediately just
you know i have a weird way to if i'm
saying that like oh i could have said
that okay okay cool i can like somehow
uh
uh pocket that for the next time um and
not even to say that exact thing the
next time it's just muscle memory too of
like getting my brain to go
because i like that when i do a full
hour and change
show it's like i plant seeds i used to
see patrice o'neal do this when i uh saw
him live where he would you know do his
brilliant act and then he would plant
these seeds of crowd work and then tie
them all together
uh by the end of the show and that's
what i uh have started doing in the last
few years and it's awesome and i it's
really fun and
uh
yeah
how did you get into like uh doing
impressions like you know you on jay
leno on uh pam and tommy right you know
then you know you you're doing dr phil
you're doing all this playing vince
mcmahon on young vince mcmahon on young
rock i mean were these something as a
young young kid you were doing
impressions yes like
what are your top impressions as a kid
well i remember i went to this like
jesus christ water sports camp with my
spit tank i was the only jew there which
the guy tried to convert me to it was my
buddies from high school
they were in a uh uh uh church group and
they took a summer
it was a camp for like 10 days it was
water sports camp so from 7am to like
four was like on the beach jet skiing
[ __ ] brilliant boobs and brilliant
and just and
and uh boats and just
basketball just fun in the sun water
sports and then
come back
dinner and then we all break off into
groups and i'd always expect yeah call
let's go back to the tent and then i was
like no come on come hang with the group
you know and so then i'd sit in the
group and him yet and then he'd take me
off to the side a few times ago
so are you are you tied to
are you tied to judaism and i go yeah i
got a bar mitzvah you know so i'm pretty
i'm pretty doubted at this point but i
did too but i just did it for the money
yeah
did you really i mean i didn't i was
you know
no i mean i guess
but i'm not religious at all i don't you
know i mean yeah i'm very reformed
and so i'm like yeah man it's it is
where it is i think it's you know i'm
just here for the good times i'm
circumcised man i'm not going anywhere
dude i had to show it to him to prove it
and um
and then i was like uh
i was like uh well let me go to the i'll
sit down and like participate
did that then they had a talent show
this is what i'm building to so that
talent show and i came up with this idea
for my buddies where i would do all
these voices and they would like lip
sync all these things so i basically
wrote our whole sketch and it was me
doing the voice i did at that time were
already i did a bill clinton
i did a kermit the frog i did a mike
tyson i did a um
schwarzenegger
uh cosby and splinter from ninja turtles
wow by the way put all those guys in a
[ __ ] reality show house
and see who comes out on top
that's amazing so it'd be like you know
be like splinter would be like you know
you know
doing something then and then kermit the
frog and then and then bill clinton you
know and they might typhoon you know and
then
god we will come through with a carpet
go to sleep you know and then um
yeah
people loved it ate it up they were like
this jews got it that's what probably
triggered you like i gotta do stand up i
gotta do
yeah stuff like that but again it was
all for shits and giggles but it was
like two but it was a fun thing to they
all looked to me being like hey funny
friend like what should we do for the
skit and i just was like hell yeah i was
like wow and so i wrote a whole thing
and we you know get ever everybody had a
script and then uh
so that was cool but and then doing
impressions of teachers and friends at
school and then like did you audition
for jay leno for yeah
so my agent hit me up and said do you
have a jay leno and i was like i had
done a couple videos uh as him
did you have to audition yeah
so did you get dressed up
i uh no but i sent a video that i had
where a friend did like a pretty decent
chin and makeup so they could see a
little bit of that because i saw the one
that recently posted with uh it's you
talking to david letterman
oh yeah it looks like both of you you're
leno and la he's letterman oh bro that's
incredible that's incredible if you go
on his instagram instagram adam right
comedy right but jeff richards who was
on snl mad tv does an amazing letterman
and a slew of other incredible
impressions and he does this now thing
for his podcast where he has people come
on and he does an impression and then
they do one or he interviews like he he
interviewed bill burr as louis anderson
but he he does the deep fake
like when we they record it on some
program and the guy spends time to
really do it i didn't realize how good
it was gonna look yeah it looks [ __ ]
incredible yeah like yeah it looks like
it's leno and letterman and so uh yeah
that was cool how do you how do you how
are you directed as someone who's doing
an impression of you're playing jay leno
yeah i mean how does what does the
director say to you uh could you give a
little or did you just let them do your
thing
yeah they definitely did like say i
think they had me tone down some of the
some of the lift beat though
you know not as much lisp you know
and uh which he does have in pockets
like i ran into him at flappers we were
on a show together about about two three
weeks ago i've done for flappers come on
man yeah well done great
and uh my mom goes you gotta tell him
that you play him i was like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] and i'm walking down the
back of the kitchen to the green room
and he just turns and looks at me goes
down with the guy who played me on tv
and i was like oh you watch it i go i'll
quit move back to seattle if you hate it
he goes no no it was good i haven't
watched him myself but i was good i
heard was grounded i heard it with him
being a cartoonist
really good so good and so then i was
like alright cool
and then uh but then yeah he goes he
goes he goes he goes i thought the chin
went a little too big i thought the
chimp and then they started just
laughing and i was like i thought it was
actually good it could have been bigger
and uh i want you to teach me how to do
that yeah you teach me how to it
the gin was too big it's kind of a lift
like that that's good yeah yeah you
could teach me yeah i mean it's
i i don't i mean yeah i don't know but
you have a good ear yeah i think that's
yeah and i don't even consider myself an
impressionist but more of i guess say
you know i feel like i've always been
able to do voices but but um
maybe a mimic yeah just having a good
ear cause there's some where i i know
certain impressionists
that are on snow that are like man i
listen i study i work on ones too i find
when i go i want to get good at that for
me it's like if i try it and it's in the
wheelhouse
then i can just do it yeah like i did
adr for robert downey jr for a couple
movies and i just go when when it came
through i was like i've never tried to
do that and i tried and i was like okay
cool i can kind of do like a
a decent one you know what does he how
does he talk so we're sitting here on uh
so rdj here so iron man one iron man two
there's uh obviously more moves i've
done heart and souls uh chocolate i
auditioned for it but johnny depp got it
but you know kerma she [ __ ] in his bed
well we don't know it tastes like human
[ __ ] i didn't eat it but i heard he did
show anyway so we're here on inside of
you or inside with you are we inside of
we're inside together the house uh the
rosenbaum bill it's a very nice house a
lot of puppets not enough puppets
someone would say but um
brilliant
but i love it yeah do you just torment
your fiance with these impressions no no
do you not do your sketch sketch your
standards
do you ever try to like you never run
lines with her you never probably said
yeah i think i've probably said like
usually after a show if i'm on the road
and she's not with me and i'll tell her
a certain moment that happened and she
thinks it's funny or she hears me
editing clips or something and and
she'll laugh but she's also a great
supporter of
she loves i mean she's now in voice over
animation casting and and when she moved
out here she was just working the
restaurant um game and crushing that and
and uh
and then started to just get more and
more around the business and then she
got into script supervising and she was
being uh scripty on sets and then she
started working in production and loved
that and then uh now she's doing this
but she comes to show i mean you know it
came last night and and uh
uh to the show and then she um
no sorry and then she um uh
she just loves it she loves being around
it and she loves sh and she also knows
my show's always different
and she you know will even like she's
really funny herself so she'll like say
she'll like you know not tell me tags
but she'll think of funny stuff and and
add on to it you know i see these but
not like gaffigan's wife who like writes
oh yeah
yeah yeah that's another level that's
another level but i i noticed like on
your instagram it's like you're friends
with the rock you're friends with dana
carvey i'm like what i'm like how many
people have to go hey could you get dana
carvey on my podcast oh yeah
a lot of people right you're like yeah
yeah i think i did did you really
probably why would i want david carvey
i'm like david carney yikes
well why wouldn't i want david carney
well
if i'm being perfectly honest david
carney
would do it he would and he would
actually help you get dana probably
better than i could david carney david
carney that was amazing that was just
you being nervous though for the idea of
him even being harney would be i would
be nervous i would be i would be a
little nervous who is david carney where
david carney fill out his backstory
uh people think he's tied to the carney
hot dog he's a former english teacher
okay um
out of hoboken he hates
turn-ons include
uh
not telling any nathan's hot dog stories
yep
or jokes
coney carney it's kearney carnea david
carney turn-offs include people that uh
don't know how to use your versus your
or you
do you ever mess that up by accident and
feel stupid oh i did it on a post the
other day and some girl hit me up and
goes hate to be this person but it's
this
and i was like you know what i actually
take pride and and yes so [ __ ] thank you
but also
i've done it with typing really fast and
i was saying you're like ugh yours
posture you got to do it it's like a lot
it's your apostrophe
i'm an idiot i judge when someone sends
it through if they don't know it right i
mean i just type fast i don't even think
about things well
maybe i should think about cleaning it
up before connie comes on how did you
become
i mean you're such a likable guy i mean
and you're funny but like the rock yeah
you're friends with him yeah you're
friends with the [ __ ] rock how did
your friendship with the rock happen so
during covid i was like i once things
shut down i was like oh we're not going
anywhere for a minute i'm talking to a
handful of comics that are like very
bummed
as i was we're like oh man and there's
some talk of like is cut is stand up
even gonna come back i mean truly there
was no sign of
of even the business coming back it was
like is that the end of tv and movies
all these people were trying to do these
like zoom shows some stand-up shows but
then like zoom tv shows or it was just
and i was like [ __ ] i mean it was such a
high level of uncertainty
and i was like well i gotta control what
i can control which is trying to you
know for myself my own sanity trying to
create and put up more content
do dumb little videos
i had a friend made me these like little
braces i would do these little
characters and then i did some puppet
stuff made some songs and then i was
like i'm just going to try to be
thinking more in terms of like just
putting up funny stuff so i see um a
post a headline that gwyneth paltrow was
selling candles that smelled like her
vagina right through her company called
goop rye right uh-huh yeah brian with me
on that one yeah um and so uh they sold
out in like 10 minutes like these
candles that smell like her vagina and i
was like whoa and then um i was and i
was like well who's the male equivalent
to that and uh
who would like to like ball scented
candles so i was like oh you know as i
posted the thing and then i just was
like and i never tagged the people but i
tagged the rock and i was like hey your
move man like [ __ ] they're going to
sell those like you know equality like
you you got to sell the ball get on that
hit up yankee doodle candle company
whatever
and then i start just as a joke and it
was really just the whole post also just
being like wow like look like how funny
the world we live in where
she made those and they sold out and
people want them it just that was to me
the the bulk of it was like this is
crazy like life is crazy don't try and
he responded and so i started getting
all these messages being like how do you
know the rock and i was like oh
everybody knows rock and then i look at
the post and he had commented on it like
brother i've been trying to get
you know uh boston kills going but i
keep burning my dick on the wax or
something like and then something else
and then he just made a joke and then
and then he followed me and then we just
started keeping in touch
and then uh
and then he sent me a couple voice notes
saying he'd been following my stuff and
keep at it we'll have some terra mono
when things resume and life gets back to
normal and then i got the audition for
vince mcmahon and and i was like i don't
know if this came from you but you know
thanks man show looks dope uh very cool
that they're you know you're doing this
um on your story and and how things came
to be and then i went uh out with a
buddy of mine to chappelle's um uh
summer camp in ohio where he lives in in
yellow springs and uh and i get a and i
had been that point been joking about i
went on like spade show and a few other
podcasts and i was
had this running bit of like the rocks
ghosting me because i left him my number
in the in the instagram thing and and
then i just hadn't heard from him for
like five months so i was just like yeah
they're actually we had this friendship
and now he's throwing it all away just
whatever it was a fun like thing to to
joke about and then i just get a text
that says hey it's dj the rock in
parentheses let me know when you get on
the phone and i had been joking about
this so i thought something one of my
advisors [ __ ] me wait he wants you to
call him yeah were you nervous yeah but
i also didn't think it was him because i
was just like again i've been joking
about this so a buddy of mine is texting
me from a number that's i don't know
saying you know what i'm saying right so
then i uh get a voicemail from the next
day and then i call him and he goes give
me your best vince mcmahon impression
and i did
and i was taking a poo at the time and
uh
i don't know why that was relevant but
it just adds to that that's where you
are that's where i was trying to paint
the picture and then got it and then
and then
that's really funny that's good i like
that yeah yeah it was it was and then we
just chatted like two hours about
everything about sports about comedy
about
single mom life about what family stuff
about sports about wrestling crowd work
and how he you know loves these clips i
post because he's like that was my
favorite part of doing it in the ring
was like breaking the fourth wall and
going off script he's like not everybody
could do it and i love to do it and and
we started really diving in on
on that aspect of performing and it was
like we've been friends for 30 years and
i was like man i should record that
whole conversation put it out as a
podcast and uh and then i even asked at
one point i go why haven't you done i
was like you gotta do stand up we gotta
do like a young rock
you know tour and he was like i could
just come out and he's like but i wanna
he's like everyone's gonna write jokes
for me they're just like the worst i
wanna come out and just bomb i was like
well yeah because if you bomb you can
just pull his shirt down a little show a
little nip everyone will go crazy you
always have a way to save the joke sure
and then he's like uh and he's got a
comic's brain too he's real quick
filthy but like articulate and and has
like a real respect for the craft but
like a real connection to it which is
why he he uh he loves performing because
he's like the wrestling which i didn't
realize i watched a decent amount of
wrestling growing up but now have
obviously gone back to really uh you
know insert myself in that world and man
like the showmanship level
at a certain time was like bonkers i
didn't really appreciate as a kid like
how much to create these characters but
then like the commitment level is like
pretty high um but anyway so then we
just uh he's just been cool man i love
that and uh great story man we don't
talk you know every week but still it's
cool he acknowledged you he likes you he
thinks you're a mutual he sent me a
video just last night of him just taking
a video of uh
of
one of the episodes coming up it was a
big scene where vince is basically
telling um
the guy uli who plays uh the oldest rock
that he's um
uh about changing his name and about
going to madison square garden pla and
doing wrestlemania for the first time
and he just sent you the clue sent me a
clip of that and then just said like
great job brother and blah blah and he's
so it's like he'll you know
that's cool and knowing that i feel like
i like him so much more now i'm gonna
follow him
that was amazing uh this is called [ __ ]
talking with adam ray these are my
patrons who i love dearly keep the show
running go to patreon.com inside of you
i'll write you a message after i i love
you thanks for supporting the show rapid
fire
gonna answer these questions here we go
you're ready for this yeah
leanne really loved the show young rock
what was it like working with the rock
himself is he as kind as he seems to be
you just kind of talked about it just
kind of broke it down but got to go
visit him on the setup black adam in
atlanta and uh i just reposted this
video he did a little uh fun video uh
with me where i was talking to his
cardboard cutout i just saw that look on
your instagram yeah yeah uh but sweet
heart of a guy and like what i think is
cool is uh no when people say like hey
let me know if you got any questions or
whatever to like to talk about you know
vince or the part of the show like every
time i've said like you got five minutes
he [ __ ] makes time and that's another
thing where you go you have no time
because you're doing everything how does
he do it i don't know i don't have any
time for and i have all the time yeah
don't know
michelle k
ah sizzle ask him if he has ever had a
joke stolen and how he handled it oh
yeah
it wasn't that same guy who stole all
those jack shepherd
no yeah man i'll say it the axe from
soldier show and i'll say it because i
love dax he's a good guy i did too um
and uh and i would love to rip it up on
his pod at some point and i would
definitely bring this up because i feel
like he's the type of guy that would uh
vibe on it so i used to do this bit this
folger's coffee bit right
it's i joke that a lot of my comrades
i've come up with like
uh
attached to me in their knowledge of
like when we started because it was like
i would open and close with it i
wouldn't but i would always whether it
was a five-minute set or a 10-minute set
or 20-minute set i was doing it where it
was this dumb joke where i would go you
know talking about the misleading
slogans and advertising and i go uh you
know so it's commercial for folger's
coffee you know um uh the best part of
waking up is forge is in your cup and i
go eh is it you know to me that's always
be the best part of waking up is not
dying in your sleep and then i'll get a
big laugh and then i'll go
yeah
and then a couple other stupid lines
after that and i was at the improv and
dax was starting to maybe pop around
like he was
doing stand-up yeah like you see
something these guys do yeah and i was
doing so yeah and so we're like oh he's
doing comedy and uh
and then somebody said oh he's maybe
just working out some stories for conan
that he's doing tomorrow so i'm like oh
even cooler i get to [ __ ] watch him
do that and then and then i'll watch
conan tomorrow and see what he works out
so i go on before him
do some stuff had a pimp my ride joke
that crushed
[Laughter]
and then uh and then the folgers bed and
i close with that and i get off and i
walk by and i was like man so nice to
meet you and he goes dude great job he
was at 40 but it's so funny i go thanks
man
cut to him watching conan the next night
and out of nowhere with no context
dax does the folgers bit
and i go
whoa
were you pissed yeah
and then i also just was like
and my buddy was like we're watching he
just goes holy [ __ ] and he goes
flattering right i go i don't know what
i feel right now but als because that
was it was the first time i had that
happen and i was what three no four
years no 2010 yeah maybe three four
years in
and uh i was like clearly i'm not gonna
do anything about it
because he's actually like what am i and
also
and my buddies like maybe he just didn't
know and we kept trying to find these
ways to like
massage it and make it better but it was
like no
he saw me do it
probably was like who's that guy exactly
nobody knows i'm doing the couch
tomorrow that's a funny thing i want to
say it although you know you think about
that i'm not defending anybody but i'm
just saying you know you hear a funny
joke and you're like oh my god that's so
funny you want to tell everybody else
that joke
you always go and tell that joke but
great now that that version of the story
works if you go if he looks on the
camera and goes this comedian last night
adam ray said that man was it funny and
i just wanted to tell you guys here too
right
i hear you yeah i hear you but when you
pass it up when you pass it off as your
own then you go oof but
uh
do you still use that joke no
but also
yeah but i credit dak shepard now
but i um
no i i uh
i
also
no uh no hard feelings no judgment cause
you're just like man i don't [ __ ]
just like i gotta get something on i
gotta be funny but at that time i guess
it was more really the idea of just like
my first taste of like oh man
write more personal [ __ ] my write more
jokes about playing wolverine at
universal studios and having a single
mom and having a [ __ ] you know white
rapper brother-in-law you know named
dirty write more stuff that's um that's
that's like that that people can't take
do you know what i'm saying that's
really what the lesson was uh
and again just trying to have that that
glass half full thing it was like all
right that sucked
but um
but what now what yeah adjust
that being said i love you dex you're
hilarious and your pod's great and um
and hey man if you [ __ ] you
but [ __ ] you no
uh raj what's the worst heckler you've
had to deal with at a show and how did
you handle them uh i had a woman throw a
wine glass at me whoa come on i was in
paso robles kicked out of course yeah
thank you
paso robles wine country
they did not have comedy up there my
buddy used to live up there he he ran a
little show upstairs brewery they packed
in about 300 people i'm doing all these
jokes about playing wolverine at
universal studios and uh that was my
life at the time so i just had 20
minutes on theme park [ __ ] and uh
and i'm looking down in between jokes
and she had said something earlier that
was a little uh off color and and just
annoying and drunk and obnoxious and i
said she at one point she goes usually
this cam gave me a cath and i was like
should i let her give me a kiss and
everyone's like yeah so i went over
there and she like licked the side of my
face and then i made some you know dumb
joke about being like oh man i know you
could get hpv and herpes and [ __ ]
blah blah and one you know lick how many
licks does it take to get to the top of
cougarmouth or something i said and uh
and then she and i walk back to the
middle stage and i'm looking down
thinking the next joke and laughs dying
down and i'm just like i just see my
peripheral vision just this
and then i just see that like from this
side and so quickly that i
didn't even have time to process it i
didn't have time to like
you know and it was just i just went
like that
did you the base of the wine glass hits
my palm and it's just sweaty enough and
hot whatever to wear like part of the
glass like
hit and stuck almost in the webbing of
my hand to where all i had to do was
just wrap around the base of the glass
kid you not i'll call brett riley right
now he's confirmed it for me before on a
podcast where i catch it out of midair
and then i slowly turn to my hand and i
go
and everybody goes nuts and i walked
over and i set it down on her table and
i said i told you i'm wolverine [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with me and people went nuts
and then they kicked her out and then i
got smoked out by this couple in the
back of their
uh [ __ ] uh subaru that had two doors
and they got into a big fight and i just
stayed in the back and i tried to like
slip out behind them because i got into
a big fight and i was like can you guys
let me out like this is getting pretty
heated and i'm very high and i don't
want to be back here and so like i
pushed the girl seat up and like
slithered out
and then uh
and then went back and then the woman
was outside the hotel where we were
staying and she like like was so drunk
and was yelling at me and was just like
you embarrassed me in front of my
friends and i was like you threw a wine
glass at me
and i caught it
and then they kicked you out
and uh
and then i uh
fell asleep in the shower fully clothed
a couple of times
and then i threw a
marie calendar's chicken pot pie at the
window and broke it
jesus christ what a night
yeah by the way do you do you even weird
question but do you even talk to your
dad
oh yeah you do oh yeah all the time i
mean i'm
once i got to college and he started
reaching out and was like i was like i'd
rather have a relationship with him than
not so he supports you he oh yeah full
on like all about it watching yeah it
sends me i think re i i rewatch this
again on youtube i really you know
always yeah and my sister's got a little
different take on things you know
so but i again i'm just like
i mean i've been there for him in more
ways than one his wife passed uh right
uh during uh kovid and so he's been by
himself now so i try to hit him up every
day
with not uh if not a text to facetime
just to you're always just the one
you're always the one reaching out to
always the one getting it making
everybody happy still that one adam
totally that's a good quality i have
that quality i believe and i uh
you could take it advantage it's
exhausting it is but you know you you
feel like you know you're doing good
some good things what's the alternative
to not do it and let him just like and
go [ __ ] i mean look yeah there's
times let someone else do it my fiance
has learned of some of the things of how
like
you know poorly treated my mom was and
how sad she was and that makes and for
how much of a gangster my mom is makes
uh me and offensive when she brings up
i'm like yeah that sucks and she's like
how do you
look at him
and not or just treat him as well as you
do after all that i'm like because at
this point what's the [ __ ] 78 like am
i really gonna hold on to that and like
it'd probably be worse for you if you
did hold on to it yeah and there was a
time where he had his gnarly surgery
about a year and a half ago and he was
in the hospital and things were a little
complicated and and he wasn't sure if he
was if how it was gonna turn out and i
went up there again and for a couple
days in oregon and stay with them and my
mom facetimed me and they
don't really talk at all
it's all through like us like how are
you doing how say hi to this or they see
each other on facebook and so they
facetime for the first time in probably
i don't know 10 years and it was a crazy
moment like and then my dad like just
broke down and said like i'm sorry to
her wow it was crazy that would never
happen with my family really that's
crazy yeah that's awesome but it never
happened we can get into my family
another time part two no uh this has
been awesome dude i love having you on
it's like do we cover everything oh my
god well you just have to come back on
okay you know a treat been one that
comes up for a long time man yeah you're
gonna do you have one yes tell everybody
about your podcast about last night
podcast find it on youtube itunes uh
pete holmes episode just dropped today
sandra bullock's been on bill burr
michael rosenbaum jason droulos i have a
badge of cares hey you have oh yeah that
was a long time ago though yeah i needed
to be a year before covent yeah yeah
over at the um
um there's a studio that was it was uh
where the the the hobbits are lord of
the rings those are the guys the hobbits
uh my friends why don't i not dom
dom
monaghan it's uh it's up on floor 20
yeah something that vine yeah yeah yeah
yeah cooler studio now over on melrose
really two minutes from here yeah across
two books your guests me see i bought
all my guests too yeah it's hard oh man
i had chubby chase uh on because his
daughter loved to have chubby cheeks his
daughter plays keyboard at the commie
store and she's a comic and she helped
facilitate that sandra i just you know
get from me melissa good lord son yeah
oh
we have to have more conversations with
adam here help me out
i can get you my i can get you dan
carney and my brother-in-law he's going
to be david carney david carney yeah i
said dan carney i think that's a real
guy oh dan who is your dream guest
though um
has anyone ever asked you that gary
oldman wow kenner reeves who i worked
with wow you work with keanu on what
yeah um on a movie called sweet november
and i played a transvestite and he was
always so wonderful to me he's like whoa
you look great
and i'm like dude thanks man he's like i
go you want to give me a hug it's like
not really
you know but i called him cantu i was
like hi cantu good morning so funny he
was great i'll show you some pictures
bro that's a pod i would i would love to
i'm close on getting him my friend dan's
really close friends with him
and i'm like i'm like dan just tell him
we did a movie together we were so cool
it's not dan carney is it it's not david
david carney david all right i love you
so much i love it too thank you thank
you for uh allowing me to be inside of
you today you were it was gentle and it
always is exactly what i expected good i
like that
there you have it thank you adam for
coming on the podcast i appreciate it
i'm gonna just give myself a quick pic
of the nose
and uh yeah thanks for coming on the
podcast that was a lot of fun talking to
him some guests uh when i'm talking to
them time goes very slowly another guest
it goes fast
because he had something to say
and uh i like when people talk
that makes my job a lot easier yeah when
they don't talk i have to get things out
of them
but um we still got some stuff out of
adam ray so thank you um
thank you for again for listening to the
podcast
thank you for supporting if you didn't
know get go the inside of you online
store to get cool merch sunspin.com to
check out when our album's coming out
and uh to buy merch and to zoom with us
and um follow us on all our handles at
incitee podcast on instagram and
facebook at insideapod on the twitter
um
i guess that's really it the patron of
course go to patreon.com inside of you
to support the podcast we need you
we need you
um and i want to thank jason nelkin for
his awesome editing ryan tez my co-host
here who's
is just the engineer slash co-host slash
guns and roses slash slash slash
and um of course bryce bryce couldn't do
it without you buddy uh my producer
bryce really puts it all together and
makes it easy for this guy to
to be able to handle all this stuff you
really help me out and uh that's about
what it is making life as easy as you
can
making bryce makes things easier for me
you make things easier for me jason it's
like it's a team man
i honestly i don't know what i would do
i would just be like all right i guess i
quit i don't know what the hell to do
what am i supposed to do
we got a good unit we got a good um
we figured it out you have a good unit i
do have a good unit
he looks into the camera
oh man now it's time for the patron
shout outs give me the drum roll
here we go
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p by the way
thank you for sticking around i know we
have the new talkville podcast uh and a
lot of people are joining patreon and it
means the world to me that a lot of
people are joining patreon for talkville
and inside of you
it's just miraculous and i hope you
don't leave inside of you um and it
means the world to me and also make sure
you listen to talkville or watch
talkville it's a really fun re-watch
podcast you can start we're only on
episode 11 so you guys can catch up
easily or just start out with the
episode that's about to air here we go
robert b jason w did i say nico p i
think i did
sophie m kristen k raj c joshua d cgp
jennifer n stacy l jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e eldon soprano 99 more
ramirez santiago m
chad w lee np
did we see leon p already no we didn't
but we'll see her again even if we
didn't janine r maya p maddie s belinda
and
nice random nice chris h dave h sheila g
brady ray h tab of the t
tom n liliana a
talia m betsy d chat l marion
n
big stevie w angel m rhiannon c correct
corey k dev next and michelle a jeremy c
andy t gavinator david
c david c john b brandy d javore camille
s the chief joey m design otg eugene and
leah nikki g corey
nick kdb nicole patricia heather l jake
b megan t mls orlando c caroline d
christine s sarah s eric h jennifer r
shane r m r
jeremy v andrew m robert g
zittoychi zetawaichi 77 he told me once
and i just keep messing it up andreas n
oracle chris r michael f karina n hi
karina samantha michelle that's samantha
w michelle d amanda r lovecraft
lovecraft ezine
cool amanda s and jen b
great those are the
top tier uh
management those are the um
those are the folks that help the
podcast
what would you do without them
nothing no
uh from the hollywood hills up in
california in the hills of california
i'm michael rosenbaum i'm ryan taylor
i'm still here you're still here giving
away the camera we love you we couldn't
do this without you and um
of course
be good to yourself
have a good week
we'll see you right here be good
yourself we'll see
[Music]